you know i mean you you you know you
suddenly have to think you know i i got
to keep a roof over this head i got to
make this mortgage i mean that's sort of
when i
started sort of when i started doing
everything
the blessing was it's when i started
doing voiceover
right and that was just a revelation
that was so much fun and
i'm so glad that that happened um but i
you know i did that kind of to stay in
town not that
not to solve any of my problems i just
did it because i wanted to
i didn't want to have to leave town to
work which is where i always had to go
but um it was always
you know i was always nervous about
keeping the roof over the head and
and doing it and you know balancing that
with
being present i wanted to be present as
well there was a period when i was like
probably
over charging for my services that took
a little while for me to realize that
wait a minute they don't do that anymore
they don't overpay for actors anymore
yeah they certainly don't right when
right when the corporations decided that
top of show is the minimum right yeah
and your quotes don't matter and all the
rest of that stuff so i think i hit a i
think i hit a high quote right when my
daughter was born right after shawshank
you know
i think that was my highest quote and
then after that it was
you know a couple years of not getting
paid that
and realizing okay i have to
i have to work i have to work for less
you know
what was the uh you know obviously
people always come up to me and they're
like oh my god clancy brown when you
guys switched
uh switched minds and the guy that was a
good one that was a good thing
yeah that was a good one the great brain
robbery
that was a good episode it wasn't i
never i don't think i ever
really worked with you and all of a
sudden you're sitting there with me
and we're just going back and forth and
you're like say your line and then you
say it like me but in your what you know
what i mean
oh it was so fun it was so fun it was i
remember us laughing going what the
it was kind of confusing it was in a way
but it was really fun and having andrea
romano who we both adore right
right directing us yeah but you know how
how fun is that too that they wrote it
and who wrote that one by the way do you
remember i don't remember who
who wrote that one yeah it wasn't bruce
i i have to look
great writers they had yeah but you know
how fun that they took those characters
and decided to do that and let us do
that you know we're looking for a way to
knew that we would like it knew that we
could pull it off and
have so much fun doing it yeah because
they could have done it with anybody
they could have done it with
any bad guy in any any superhero but you
know
i i take that as a big compliment it was
the play i was playing lex luthor on
smallville you were the voice of lex
i was voicing the flash in the justice
league and then
we switched then we switched and it was
just all this yeah
it was great it was really great